to not let it be but
andrew is a brilliant researcher and
here he is he's now in
uh university of massachusetts and
we look forward to a very good talk from
him andrew okay thanks debtor i was
dreading what sedible would say but
thank you
okay so this talk is mainly about linear
sketches and i suspect most of you
familiar with the idea of linear
sketches
is it still on
okay i'll continue
indeed
okay so sketches are just what computer
scientists tend to call random linear
projections so the basic idea is you
have some data it could be a file it
could be some network traffic it could
be anything you like
you encode it as a big long vector
and then you use random linear
projections to compress this big long
vector
as such
and we call this projection of the
vector into a small dimensional space
the sketch of the data and the idea is
that we design the properties of the
projection matrix m or if it's a random
matrix the distribution over matrices
such that we can infer useful properties
about the vector from the sketch of the
vector
okay
um it's a
fairly simple idea but there's already
an extensive theory on linear sketches
and there's connections to compressed
sensing to metric embeddings you've all
heard about johnson lindestrous
it's also a widely applicable technique
so the linearity of sketching means that
it's immediately applicable in the data
streaming and distributed setting so for
example if you have some data and you
sketch it and i have some data and i
sketch it we can work out the sketch of
the union of the data just by adding
together those two sketches so
embarrassingly parallel
there are many many positive results out
there
am i doing something wrong
yes
so there are many positive results out
there about your s being very very
special
it's over there
i can turn it off
okay maybe if i stay very still
um many positive results
uh about estimating various numerical
quantities about the vector um the
estimating the support size estimating
the entropy of a distribution divided by
the vector frequency moments quantile
histograms in fact just yesterday
we heard from both michael and petros
about linear regression which is another
application of sketches
so previously at the workshop
so we had the regression problem i gave
you a big matrix a
and along uh vector b
and you were trying to find an x such
that a x equals approximately b
so underlying the
like you know for all the work all the
great work that was being done was the
following idea you're basically kind of
projecting down this big input into a
sketch space so projecting down the big
matrix a into a small matrix a
same for b
and then just solving the original
problem on the sketch data in the sketch
space so as i said the underlying idea
was to reduce a big input into a small
input and then run an algorithm in
sketch space
so sketches were a natural fit for this
sort of problem and indeed a natural fit
for many linear algebraic problems just
because a linear operation in sketch
base corresponds directly to a linear
operation in the original space
so
in other words kind of linear sketches
respect linear homomorphisms
so the basic theme of things i've been
thinking about for the last couple of
years
can be broken down into two following
very general problems so sketching is a
great technique widely used a lot of
nice theory
can we extend linear sketches to not
just like kind of look at problems which
are kind of numerical but can we also
use linear sketches to
try and analyze kind of more
combinatorial or theoretical structure
or maybe group theoretic structure
that's question number one
question number two
is so trivially
linear sketches are homomorphic respect
to linear operations can we make them
homomorphic to other operations
because then maybe there's a larger set
of algorithms we could hope to
run on the compressed representation of
the data rather than original data and
this would be a great win for for big
data the idea being that i know at a
theoretical abstraction the way you
process big data is you start off with
big data
you run a big algorithm on a big
computer and you get an answer
now the appeal here would be that you
first of all compress the data and just
compress the big data and small data you
ran a more lightweight algorithm on the
small data and hopefully got the same
answer so
it's an abstraction i'm a theorist
okay so um
before i get into technical details i
want to give you a couple of concrete
examples of the types of results that
kind of
fit into this kind of larger research
agenda
one on graphs and
one that's slightly more kind of that's
about text or kind of group theoretical
structure
so first of all the first problem
is
we can imagine as a communication
problem
so that we have an adjacency matrix of a
graph
and there are n players
each player has one row of this
adjacency matrix
alternatively you could think about you
have n players like maybe the n people
here you each have a list of your
friends that corresponds directly to a
row of adjacency matrix
the question is is it possible for you
to take your
your big long like length n row
adjacency matrix sketch it can press it
down to a small number of bits
such that
a third party who comes along and just
looks at these sketches or these
fingerprints can determine connectivity
properties of the graph
so the result we show
okay so
every player with an address book caps
it down to a small space sketch or
fingerprint
so result we show is that sketches of
size poly logarithmic in n the number of
players suffice and i think on the face
of it this is maybe slightly surprising
why is that
well
let's consider two players in particular
let's say you know
alice has this address book and bob has
this address book okay
and let's suppose there is a bridge
between alice and bob
so an edge that connects alice and bob
and if it's if that edge is there the
graph is connected if that edge is not
there the graph is not connected
well it seems
that at least ours or bob needs to send
a large message or
construct a large sketch
if i'm to be able to deduce connectivity
properties just by looking at the
sketches so the reason is fairly simple
um
i need to know about the existence of
that edge from the sketches
but because each of these players
only has one row of the adjacency matrix
or only has this very local view of the
graph equivalently
alice has no reason to think this edge
is any different from the omega n other
edges that might be incident to her and
similarly for bob so if bob is so if
ours or barbers send a constant number
of bits of information about that edge
they seem to need to send the customer
bits about all the instant edges
so it seems
like at least one of these fingerprints
would need to be omega n bits long
so
we'll show that that's not the case and
it surprises the
polygraphic number of bits hi
okay so um
okay in terms of so so the adjacency
matrix partitioned between the players
the adjacency matrix is defining a graph
on those n nodes and i'm interested
if that graph if that undirected graph
is connected i want to say it is
connected with high probability and if
it's not connected i would say it's
disconnected with high probability is
that what you're getting at
ah
we could generalize it to specific pairs
but the way i'm going to talk about the
results is in terms of connectivity of
the entire graph
okay you know who your friend oh so the
question was like if for the camera like
you know it seems that to kind of um
it would suffice out one bit to
determine whether graph is connected or
not connected okay so you're a player in
this in this game you can see who your
friends are
you're going to send me a message i'm
going to look at that message and i'm
going to say whether the graph is
connected or not
but you don't know because your local
view whether the graph is globally
connected you can only send me
information that's relevant to you
and same for everyone else in the room
so that's
yes like yeah
okay um in more concrete terms really we
can come up with a sketch of every row
so it starts off as an n by n matrix so
each player is like kind of so we're
going to take every row of the adjacency
matrix count it down to a log n bit
um
vector yes but just because that's all
you can do you only know one row of the
matrix that's all you can take care of
any other
questions okay
um so i'd say it seems somewhat of a
surprising result
given that every player in this game
only has limited knowledge of the graph
somehow everyone can just do a little
bit of work
based on their global abilities and
their local information and yet i can
infer a global property from each of
these short sketches
so the second result i want to talk
about
um
is more connected to traditional
fingerprinting so
when we when we found this result we're
actually looking at
estimating the edit distance between
files
and
when you're trying to work out the edit
distance between two files the number of
substitutions
um
and deletions insertions you need to do
to turn one file into another
a metric that kind of keeps cropping up
is called the shift distance i kind of
is one file
close to being a cyclic rotation of
another file
so for example
if this file was the quick brown folks
jumped to the laserdog
and
this file was quick brown fox jumped
over lazydawg
we'd say like these two files are cyclic
rotations of one another and so we'd say
they're
they're identical modular shifts okay
so the second result
i'm going to mention
is a way for each of the um a way to
fingerprint these files
so construct a small
representation of each file
such that such that just by looking at
these fingerprints we can tell whether
the the two files are cyclic rotations
or whether they're close to being secret
rotations i
under a small number of substitutions
whether they become
cyclic rotations
and the result we proved was that
sketches or fingerprints of these files
like not normally when you do
fingerprinting you kind of hope that the
fingerprint you have a length end file
ends up being
logarithmic in length
of the file the result we found was that
um sketches of size proportional to the
number of divisors of n
were both necessary and sufficient to
solve this problem
okay and so by number of devices i don't
mean number of prime devices ben i mean
like
if the number is 10 i have kind of
i guess
uh 1 2 5 and 10 i don't think
why is this surprising
well fingerprinting sketching is
ostensibly about compression
and here we have a compression scheme
where the size of the compressed
representation is not even monotonic in
the size of the original file so i'll
hopefully say about a few words about
how that comes up
okay so
i want to talk about both results
briefly
so for connectivity i'm first of all
going to talk about this basic
connectivity results and then i'm going
to talk about some extensions
to not just like you know determine
where the graph is connected but based
on all the end difference small
fingerprints
um estimate like you know the size of
every cut in the graph for the spec
spectral properties of the graph
uh this is joint work with cooked in and
sodium
and there's also some related work with
club students at amherst michael crouch
and daniel stamps
okay
so as i said
the problem the the algorithm we're
trying to improve or the scheme we're
trying to come up with is that
everybody takes their role their
adjacency matrix collapses down to a
short vector and from the short vectors
i can determine connectivity properties
okay
a corollary of this result is actually
going to be the first
dynamic graph stream algorithms so
instead the standard model for graph
streaming is that i give you a sequence
of edges
and over time these edges build up this
glorious great big graph
and your challenge is to compute
interesting properties of this graph
given that you can't store all the edges
i'm presenting to you so
all previous work on this problem
had assumed that there could only be
edges inserted into the graph and so the
big graph was described by sequence of
edge insertions
a consequence of the sketching results
are going to be the first data stream
results that also handle deletions in
addition to insertions
okay
so let me show you how i'll
let me try and kind of the currency
result is not too difficult so let me
try and give you enough details so you
can walk away thinking you understand it
there's going to be some things i'll
gloss over but i'll try and point those
out when i get to them
okay
so remember that the picture progression
take your original input
kind of
kind of sketch it basically can shrink
the original input and solve it and
solve the problem in the sketch base
well the idea for this connectivity
algorithm is going to be very similar so
you're each going to take your road
adjacency matrix sketch it send it to me
and then i'm going to emulate a
connectivity algorithm
on the sketches
and then
like if hopefully i'll determine the
graph is connected if not with the graph
described by this adjacent matrix is
connected
okay so we're emulating a classical
algorithm in sketch space
so the natural question is what
algorithm should we emulate and the
other one we're going to emulate is very
simple
so
for every node of a graph in fact
here's a graph so for every node we're
going to pick an incident edge
so say these red edges here
after we pick those red edges we've got
two connected components now we're
moving
second step of the algorithm
so for every connected connected
component we're going to pick an instant
edge of which there's only one this guy
so we pick it
after we pick that edge
these two connected components have
collapsed to one connected component and
we can conclude the graph is connected
so this algorithm had nothing to do with
streams or sketches this was just a
simple kind of basic algorithm uh in the
kind of classical computation model okay
and the only thing you need to know
about it something which is
fairly simple to prove
is that after log n rounds of this
algorithm
these red edges you've picked will
include a spanning tree or a spanning
forest of the graph
okay so this is the basic out
connectivity algorithm we're going to
try and run
on the compressed representation of the
graph basically the representation i get
by looking at all the fingerprints
you've sent me
okay so the next question is
well how do you go about compressing
your rows of adjacency matrix
such that i could emulate this
algorithm homomorphically
okay
so
how do i emulate the algorithm via
sketches
so i'm going to give you a recipe to
follow to turn your adjacency row into a
sketch
the first thing you do
is you
encode
your neighborhood
if you're the i player in this game you
encode your neighborhood as the vector
ai
and ai is the i throw the signed vertex
edge matrix which you heard about from
petros yesterday and you'll probably
hear about more from nikhil later today
or tomorrow
so
concretely let's say this is still our
original graph
so a1 is going to be a vector
indexed by all node pairs so 1 2 1 3 1 4
etc so it's going to be in general n
choose 2 entries
and the non-zero entries of this vector
are going to correspond to instant edges
to node one
so instant edges are one two
and one three for node one lo and behold
the non-zero entries of this vector is
in positions one two and one three
okay we can do this for all the
um
all the nodes of the graph so for a2
so for the second node the instant edges
are one and three so the non-zero
entries are one two two three everything
else is zero
and i've just introduced a slight little
wrinkle that as opposed to putting
so for the non-zero entries in a one i
put everything was going to be a one
for the non-zero entries in a2 i made
some of the minus one my rule is as
simple as
if you don't know node i
and you connect someone with a higher
label you're going to put a one in there
if you're creating someone with a lower
label you can write minus 1 there
so why do i want to do this
well if i do this i get this nice
property
that
for any subset of nodes s
if i look at the vector i get by summing
up the appropriate ai vectors
then the non-zero
entries
of
this vector here correspond exactly to
the edges across the cut from s to the
rest of the graph
so for example if i had this cut of one
and two and i summed up the
corresponding vectors a1 and a2
and ended with this vector
the non-zero entries are 1 3
2 3
lo and behold the edges across this cuts
is 1 3 and 2 3.
okay so that's the first thing you do
you take your row of adjacency matrix
that you own you encode it in this way
then you appeal to an existing result in
the data streams lecture on what's
called l0 sampling you know you don't
need to know much about l0 or something
i'm going to treat it like a black box
i'm happy to talk about it at the break
if you want in more details
so the idea is that your sketch is going
to be a random projection of
the vector ai you've just defined
this random projection you're going to
pick in such a way that it has the
following property
so m basically going to maps large
vectors down to very short vectors
but it has the property that for any x
any vector x
you can recover a non-zero entry of x
just by looking at the projection
um mx
okay
so that's all there is to it so you've
taken your row the adjacent matrix and
code as a i and applied m to it
m is mapped your length n vector down to
a log n bit vector
and so that's your sketch you can send
the send that to me
now i go about trying to emulate that
classical algorithm that i showed you in
the previous slide
and to do that
um i think about what operations did i
need to emulate that algorithm
at various points all i the only
question i had was for a given connected
component maybe corresponding to a set
of
nodes s
can i find an incident edge on that
connected component
and based on these sketches sure i can
and i can do that in the following way
so
if i want to find an edge across the cut
s
what i do
is i look at the sketches i received
from the corresponding players
and i add them up
okay by the linearity of my sketch
matrix m
the sum of the sketches equals the
sketch of the sum
property of m the sketching matrix
i can post process this projection and
find a non-zero entry of this vector
here
and remember we set up these ai vectors
exactly
so that non-zero entries of this vector
correspond to exactly
edges across the cutouts i've been
interested in yeah
yes
yeah so yeah so the clarification
question was that
what was the um
yeah the given mx
for any x you can reconstruct some
non-zero enter of x you don't get to
choose which one you recover but you can
recover one of them
okay
so let's see how am i doing for time
okay
so any questions on that
so that was just a simple way for you to
to sketch your local data your local
neighborhood such that from all these
sketches i can emulate a connectivity
algorithm i inlet current connectivity
algorithm and i output the graph is
connected if and only if
my algorithm is seeded
okay
so
it's a simple algorithm but as i said i
think it's slightly surprising kind of
given
that it came very very personally close
to a kind of communication complexity
low band
in fact even there's there's a nice
result by uh shin zhang kind of jeff
phillips and ella
verbian
i kind of
from a couple of sodas
sort of two years ago that said that if
the edges were arbitrarily partitioned
between n players then there's no way
you could have a kind of an efficient
sketching protocol so it's very
important that every player in this game
every communicating player had an entire
row of the matrix rather than some
arbitrary subset of the
of the entries
so it's surprising that we do
connectivity i think it's even more
surprising that we can go beyond
connectivity and estimate many
connectivity
properties of the graph in fact we can
do
cut specification and spectral
specification
so
um
there'll be a talking spectral
specification later but let me just like
kind of
give you some basics
so that there's a generic algorithm that
will so sorry spar spiral graph is a
weighted sub graph
of the original graph that's um
like kind of the number of edges is
almost linear in the number of nodes and
yet if you look at this specifier like
if you look at the property of the
specifier they're very good approximate
approximations to properties of the
original graph
so there's a general algorithm for form
for constructing these spectral for
construction specifiers and that works
as follows
so you sample every edge of
the graph you every edge you be at the
graph with some probability puv and if
you sample the that edge you weight it
with pro with with weight one over puv
and it's simple to some symbol to it's
obvious that if you do this process the
expected weight of any cut is preserved
but from the tasks show that if pub is
i know
emitting some like messy factors but
basically if puv
is bigger than one over the minimum uv
cut
then concentration measure kicks in
and
the weighted subgraph you'll end up with
is such that
every cut in that graph is when the
factor the weight of every cardinal
graph is within a factor one plus
epsilon all the way to the original
graph
so
spielman's schroder had this result that
pub is bigger than the effect of
resistance
um
of an edge
then we'll get a one plus epsilon
spectral sparsifier
and so a special specifier won't go into
details but basically it generalizes a
cut specifier cut specifier allows you
to approximate every cut in the graph
special specifier is going to allow you
to estimate things like kind of the
eigenvalues properties of random walks
natural cluster strings of the graph
okay
effective resistance is just like um
again petross mentioned this yesterday
if you take your graph oops
and you add one ohm resistors to move
every edge
r u v is the potential difference you'd
get if you inject one unit of flow at u
and extracted it at b
and by
koko's laws etc you can
you can
this will uniquely define ruby
so
the next result i want to briefly
mention
is that
using small sketches like everyone sends
me a small sketch of their their row of
adjacency matrix again
i can actually
emulate the sampling that goes on in
these algorithms
so concretely what this is going to mean
as a corollary is that so previously it
was like use everyone individually sends
me poi log n bits i can work out where
the graph is connected
what we can do generalize this to is if
you send me one or epsilon squared pi
log n bits just about your node i can
estimate all cuts on the graph
and if you send me that times some small
polynomial n like n to the two thirds
i can also estimate all spectral
properties
there's an actual open problem there to
try and reduce that into the two-thirds
but i'm not going to get into that
um let's see how am i doing for time
okay so i can briefly mention how we'd
emulate this
this sampling
any questions so far
okay
so our goal as i said is you want is
from the sketches we want to be able to
sample an edge e with probability
proportional to
sorry something i should have said in
the previous slide
so i'm going to show you how we can
sample engines with the probability t
over c uv if t is roughly one this is
going to give us
cut specification
if t is roughly n to the two thirds this
is going to give us spectral
specification so i'm going to present
this kind of
sketch and proceed the sampling
procedure for general t
so yeah goal is to sample every edge
edge e with probability
um t divided by c e where c e was the
connectivity of that edge
okay
so as a black box i'm going to use a
slight generalization of that
connectivity results i showed you a
while ago
so the connectivity results said base
from these small sketches you send me i
can find a spanning force of the graph
you can actually generalize this
if you make the sketches
k times as large
i can guarantee the property that from
the sketches i receive i will be able to
find all the edges
in any cutlet that has less than k edges
okay and we'll call this collection of
edges a k skeleton
okay
and so so the algorithm for
sampling edges is going based on these k
skeletons
so i have my original graph g that's
kind of knowledge about g is spread out
amongst everyone in the room
based on your local information
i'm going to define a sequence of login
graphs not just g but g1 g2 g3 where gi
is the graph where i subsample every
edge with probability one over two to
the i
okay
so you
okay you can all that you can all do
that separately this can sub sampling
procedure and then you basically just
send me the sketches so that i can
construct a k skeleton
for each of those graphs g1 g2 up to g
log n
okay
and then the claim is
any edge in the graph
is going to be in one of these k
skeletons with probability at least t
over c e
which was the sampling probability i
wanted to guarantee
uh let me sketch the proof of that
so let's
big c be the edges in the min uv cut of
g
okay
for some value of i
between 1 and log n in particular for
this value of i
the expected number of edges in that cut
restricted to gi
is going to be roughly t
and the properties of the k skeletons is
that for any cut
for
for any cut less than size k
i will find all the edges
so we set k to be roughly 2t
so this means for this value of i
all the edges in c
restricted to gi
appear in our k skeleton
okay
so what this means is that if an edge
isn't gi
it's going to be in hi
okay and the probability an edge is in
gi
was going to be 2 to the minus this
quantity which is exactly t over c
okay
so that's the basic idea how i'd go from
not just estimating connectivity
properties and this kind of
communication in this distributed
framework
i could also do the sampling which would
then lead me to be able to do cut
specification and spectral specification
so let me briefly
talk about this misalignment problem
okay so in this
so if you take these sketching results
out of the communication or dispute
framework and apply them to data streams
this would mean that
again you have this dynamic
graph stream of edge insertions and
deletions i can construct a cut
specifier in that setting in the
semi-streaming model basically space
proportions number of nodes and i can
construct the spectral specifier in
space roughly n to the five thirds
any other questions
okay
okay so from this misalignment this was
a problem we started looking at because
we were trying to solve edit distance in
the end we ended up proving
lower bounds on how you could sketch
edit distance but we have this
interesting positive result
um about cyclic distances so let me show
you that result now
oh sorry and this is joint work with
alexander and dhoni asap goldberg and la
porat
okay
so
so the goal was we were trying to kind
of come up with a way to fingerprint or
to sketch files
um
that would allow us not just not to just
check whether two files were identical
which is this typical setup for
fingerprints but also check whether are
they identical under some cyclic
rotation or are they close to being
identical
okay so the theorem is as follows that
there's so let's say dn is the number of
divisors of n
so
we can project down a length n file
to
roughly d of n times polylog n bits
we'll call this a fingerprint
so these fingerprints are the following
three properties
a they're useful which is always a good
property to have so by this i mean that
if you have two files or two vectors a
and b
just by looking at f of a and f of b the
two fingerprints of these two files i
can work out whether a and b are
rotations of each other cyclic rotations
okay like like going from this to this
this finger is homomorphic
with respect to rotation
operations so if you give me a
fingerprint of a file
i can then manipulate that fingerprint
without looking at the original file
such that after manipulation i have the
fingerprint of a rotation of the
original file
okay so there's operations in sketch
space which correspond to rotations in
the original space and lastly it's
homework with respect to linear
operations so for example if i have a
fingerprint of one file and a feedback
file i can find out the fingerprint of
the the addition of the two files
which is important if i want to apply
these ideas and data streams or
distributed settings
so the theorem is um
so as i said like if this is not this
this strange dependence on n
doesn't just like kind of
crop up in an upper bound in which case
it might be um
evidence that somehow we weren't
analyzing the album correctly it's
actually kind of tight
you can if you want a fingerprint scheme
that has these properties
then the size of the fingerprints does
need to be roughly d of n bits
okay
and as i said there's extensions like
kind of when
these two files aren't perfect rotations
of each other
let me briefly give you an idea for how
these fingerprints or these sketches
would work
okay thanks
so let's start with um actually
something siddiqui told me when giving
pres sorry
um good question so it makes
less sense if you're thinking about text
files it would be
think about it more that's
you know
some posi you know some character
characters of the file
maybe you know the the second ninth 10th
and 11th characters of the file i know
the rest like you know what i'm trying
to do is that you can fingerprint what
you know i can think of what i know and
then we can put them together to get
fingerprinted in the entire text
um
okay
any other questions
okay cool
so this was something sedible told me
oh it taught me when giving
presentations sometimes it's actually
very educational to first of all show
you that something that doesn't work
okay
so let me show you a fingerprint that
doesn't work for this problem
but it almost works and if you're trying
to fix this up we'll set you on the
right track for coming up with the right
solution
so the idea starts fairly naturally
first of all we're going to encode a
file using cop ravine fingerprints
so for some prime value p and some r
we're going to encode the text a0 a1 up
to a n minus 1
as the polynomial a naught plus a one r
plus a two r squared
all the way up to a n minus one r to the
minus one mod p
okay
it's our classic thing to do
then we go about thinking well can we
pick
we're going to pick r randomly but can
we pick p in such a way
so that's such that you know it will
allow us to check whether um two files
are sticking shifts of each other
so
an idea could be if we
pick p to be n plus one
assuming n plus one is prime
then my feminist little theorem with
this nice property that r to the n
equals one mod p
okay and what this would mean is that if
i had the fingerprint of a file
i can apply a simple operation to that
fingerprint and get a fingerprint of the
rotation of that file
so if i had the fingerprint of a naught
up to a n minus 1 i multiply it by r
and i go through the algebra and then
after the n is going to turn into a one
i end up with a fingerprint
of a rotation of the file here
okay and more generally if i
took a fin print multiplied by r to the
k
then i'd end up with
the fingerprint of the file shifted by k
places
okay
this is looking good
because this means that
you sketch the file you guys go to the
file a you guys sketch the file b
what i can do is i can just
ask whether i can find some k such that
r to the k times your fingerprint
equals yours guys fingerprint if there
is i want to conclude that the two files
that take the rotations of each other
and if there isn't i want to conclude
they're not
okay
okay so i can define g of r to be the
difference of r
k times the fingerprint you guys sent me
minus the fingerprint you guys sent me
okay
so at this point we hope sport simple
comes to our rescue
so smart simple says that well if we
picked r randomly
the probability of this happening
if a and b are not
k shifts of each other should be low
okay so the probability g of r evaluates
to zero
we want to say if a and b are not
signatures of each other we want to say
that g of r
with high probability is zero
but unfortunately this doesn't quite
work out so support sample would say
that
the probability of a polynomial of
degree
um i guess it was degree
n or three minus one evaluating to zero
if the polynomial itself is not zero
should be the degree n minus one divided
by the field side of p
but because we kind of closely could
have made p and n interrelated
the probability of getting kind of this
false match
is actually almost one
so
from this false start we end up defining
some fingerprints
where there are no false negatives but
there could be many false positives many
false matches
okay any questions
okay so that's what doesn't work so
please pay attention to the next slide
which doesn't work
okay so the idea is to go beyond smart
simple and what i mean by this is like
if you want to check a polynomial of
degree n
is the zero polynomial or if you want to
check the polynomial of max degree n is
a zero polynomial well natural thing to
say is well i need to check it on n plus
one points and check that they all about
to zero
this of course is not the entire picture
like if
if i know for example the coefficients
of my
my polynomial oral integer
and i'm evaluating on a non-algebraic
number i know that's not going to
evaluate to zero unless the polynomial
is the zero polynomial and so we're
going to exploit similar ideas here
so so previously i was setting p such
that for any r i could divide my
polynomials on r to the n was going to
equal to one
okay
so
for the full solution to work i want to
run in a larger field
but restrict the r i'm going to try to
roots to enter roots of unity in this
larger field
okay
and where this
where this idea of like not having to
check so many potential roots of my
polynomial to check that it's zero is
going to come in
is via cycle atomic polynomials
so
i'm picking i'm going to use the root r
of this polynomial
and check and evaluate g on that on that
value
and first of all we're going to know
that x n minus 1 factorizes as d n
irreducible polynomials over the
rationals okay so x of 10 minus 1
factorizes this and this is as far as
you can factorize it in the rationals
okay
i'm going to argue
that at least one of those factors phi i
has no shared roots with g
the reason this is true
is
phi i is irreducible so you can show
that if phi a i shares one root with g
it's going to share all roots with g
that's able's irreducibility theorem
so yeah surprise shares all roots with g
means phi divides g
but it can't be the case that's
all phi i's divide g because g is
a polynomial degree n minus one
so there must be some phi i that doesn't
divide g so there must be some fire that
shares no roots with g
okay
well what this means
is that well we don't know which phi i
shares no roots with g
but it means that it's sufficient to
just try one root from every phi i from
phi 1 phi 2 phi 3
up to
5 d of n
okay and that's where this dependence
on d of n is going to come from
okay
now here i was talking about like kind
of doing all this in
the rational field
which is of course problematic because
some of the roots of these five eyes are
going to be kind of kind of horrible
complex numbers and there's no there's
going to be no guarantee that when i
evaluate g on one of these complex roots
i end up with a number i can store and
find that precision
so at this point we can go back to
working with modular p but we need to
um
so support simple was like saying you
fix your prime field you choose a random
multi-value polynomials
what we've ended up with
is we're going to take a specific set of
dn values are
and
we're going to work in a finite field of
random size so it's going to be modulus
and random prime p
of course once we go back from working
from the rationals matches some finite
fields like it might be
that this statement is is broken there's
no longer the case that one of the five
eyes has no shared roots with g
but we can show by kind of analyzing
what's called the polynomial resultant
and its connection to kind of
determinants of sylvester matrices
that this is unlikely to happen and so
that's the basic idea behind
the
fingerprints for checking whether two
files are close to being sick and shifts
to one another
two minutes one minute
okay so let me briefly mention something
about
the lower bound
um
like
based on the last two slides about the
upper bound
uh if you if you can flesh out the
details of that last bullet point you're
pretty much there on the upper bound um
i'm only going to very very briefly
sketch the lower bound
so the idea is the low band is going to
be based on a recovery sort of argument
so that if you send me the fingerprints
of your file
i'm going to argue by
by manipulating this fingerprint
using the operations i'm allowed to use
basically kind of these additions the
linear operations and the rotation
operations i can actually recover
d of n bits of your original file from
the fingerprint
which of course means the fingerprint
must be at least have at least
d um d of n bits in it okay
so
the idea is so say your file was a
naught a1 a2 up to a5
and i've got the fingerprint you've sent
me the fingerprint of this file
well i can do something like i can
compute the sum of all these entries as
follows i can take the the fingerprint
you sent me
i could then
manipulate it so that i have now the
fingerprint of the rotation of what you
sent me
and the fingerprint of it twice rotated
all the way up to the fingerprint of
the almost full rotation of the file if
i add all these things together
these these six fingerprints
that i've constructed from the
fingerprint you sent me i get the
fingerprint of a very boring file that
goes alpha alpha alpha alpha alpha alpha
okay
so i can try and work out alpha now
just by comparing the fingerprint i've
got which is of alpha alpha alpha alpha
alpha to
the fingerprint of a mock file gggg
and i can range over all vitamin g until
i get a match at which point i've
learned alpha
okay i can do a similar thing
by not adding together all rotations of
my file
but maybe
adding together adding together every
second rotation so if i add
the fingerprint you sent me
i construct the fingerprint of the twice
shifted file
and the four times shifted file i get
the fingerprint of the file beta gamma
beta gamma beta gamma
and i can easy to argue that beta plus
gamma must equals alpha i already know
alpha
so then it's sufficient from so
basically now i've got into that simple
form i can compare this to
a fingerprint of a mock file g t prime g
g prime gg prime until i get something
that matches at which point i nano beta
and gamma and i can do this trick
for all
factors of n
and or sorry all divisors of n
and therefore can recover like a dfn
bits of information about your file
which means the sketch must have been
the event based long
so in summary
basic idea between homophobic sketches
was to kind of
sketch the type of compression so we're
going to use them to kind of compress
your data such that we can run kind of
classical algorithms be their regression
or be their connectivity algorithm
um
are they compressed data directly and
what's very nice about this compression
scheme is it's immediately applicable to
the parallel and the streaming setting
i'll give you a couple results and
graphs
so that
at a high level the statement was that
there's a formal dimensionality
reduction for graphs
a linear dimensionality reduction i
guess it's important to say that
preserves structural properties this
enables the first results in dynamic
graph streaming
and then there was this work on
misaligned data
and we showed tight upper and lower
bounds on the length of the fingerprints
necessary to detect to check whether two
files will stick the rotations of each
other and the surprising thing about
this fingerprint was that there was this
tight
upper and lower bound in terms of length
of fingerprints on this kind of numeric
number theoretic property that really
should have nothing to do with
compression and yet kind of turned up in
our proofs so thanks very much
that's a very good question
um yeah you um
so the question was um normally in
streaming algorithms it's very nice that
you don't don't need to know the length
of the stream ahead of time
for this for this problem if you wanted
to use these
signature fingerprints in the streaming
setting you would need to know the
length of the the vector or the file
you're trying to process with ahead of
time there'll be no way to get around
that